-Today is Friday, and that's
usually when I catch up
with some personal stuff.
I check my inbox,
I return some e-mails,
and, of course,
I send out thank you notes.
I was just running a bit behind,
so I'd like to write out
some right now.
James, can I get some thank you
note-writing music, please?
♪♪
Fantastic.
-He's humming
the "Curly Shuffle."
-Doesn't even look at
the keys anymore.
-Yeah, he doesn't even need it.
-He knows the...
-I don't think he's playing it.
-He finally learned the song.
-Yeah.
♪♪
Thank you, Beyoncé's new song,
"Break My Soul,"
or as Adele put it, "A song
that breaks your soul?
Stay in your lane, girl."
[ Applause ]
[ Laughter ]
Thank you,
Hostess' new cryptocurrency
themed snack cake,
$TWINKcoin...
[ Laughter ]
...for telling the world
you know what crypto is,
but you don't know what
Urban Dictionary is.
[ Laughter ]
-Give us two Twinkcoin.
-Uh...
Thank you, sending
your kids to summer camp
for basically saying, "Here,
they're your problem now."
[ Applause ]
Do whatever.
I like this one.
-You like this one?
-Thank you, trucker hats,
for just being regular hats
with a screened-in back porch.
[ Applause ]
Thank you, COVID vaccines
for kids under 5
for finally making it okay
to cough on a baby again.
[ Laughter ]
-What?
-[ Coughing ]
[ Imitates baby crying ]
-Thank you, lightbulbs,
for being a very old idea
that gets to be the symbol
of all new ideas.
[ Applause ]
-I grok. That's deep.
-Thank you, going to the beach,
for being 15 minutes of fun
followed by 6 weeks of finding
loose patches of sand
on your body.
Ahh! Still?
Thank you, waterslides, for
letting me know what it's like
to be flushed.
There you have it, everybody!
Those are thank you notes!